[Music]
you know I recently issued a challenge
to our viewers to try and find a mistake
on the show and so far there have been
many challengers but no one's been able
to knock the king off his throne all
right whatever anyway well now you know
but seriously people been writing in
they think they found actual errors and
so far we've refuted all of them well
now a fan named Lucas Perez claims to
have caught a mistake he says it
happened when Andy and I were talking
last week about an upcoming movie Pig
Conan I was actually just watching your
episode from March 31st and any you were
talking about new superhero movies
coming out and Andy actually says the
new Thor movie hey you know heroes they
keep Green Lantern's coming up they've
done Hulk a couple times you know words
coming out exactly I just wanted you to
know that Thor is not a superhero
he's a Norse God so yeah
[Applause]
thank you very much wow that guy has
nerve first of all Lucas you're dead
wrong about Thor he is in fact a
superhero we looked into it
check out this rare video made at an
accountants office okay I've got your
1040 all done all I need is your
signature and occupation Norse God right
no superhero superhero God
[Applause]
[Music]
anyway looks like another one's bit the
dust the challenge still stands though
if you think you've spotted an error on
our show report it at team koco.com
slash ha ha I found an error we will
sort it out right here on the air let's
see if you've got what it takes to make
chunk meat out of the maestro we'll take
a break when we come back Tracy Morgan